Boomers also have this very interesting
victimhood complex like they're always
aggrieved they're aggrieved like every
time you're on the phone with one of
them like you know like my aunt for
example during covet she goes I hope
everyone gets this vaccine because I'd
like to do some traveling and I've
worked my whole life I'm like everyone's
worked their whole life yeah yeah
everyone's work they're home who hasn't
worked they're a whole lot like she does
I've worked my whole life like I'm like
everyone's worked their whole life you
crazy [__] like a horse stir [__]
but again it was all about her she's
like I'd like to travel what about me
what about me